you guys would smash up dressing rooms
just because you you felt like that's
what you were supposed to do you didn't
realize that it would cost you money but
you had probably
worshipped a bunch of bands well yeah i
mean
throwing tvs out of
of
of of hotels that was
just all the stuff we read and like
cream magazine or the stuff back in the
day of you know led zeppelin and you
know uh right getting away with with all
kinds of chaos we felt that that was
well that is what you're supposed to do
on tour so i think probably more in the
jagermeister days that stuff made us
crazy like really crazy um but what do
you mean
what do you mean
bill graham remember bill graham was
like the legendary promoter that took
the rolling stones onto him and he
basically ran san francisco obviously in
the best of ways and the first big show
that we played uh
we got to open for where so the
legendary shows back then remember all
those stadium gigs in the 70s at
aerosmith and blue ester cold and
leonard skinner then everybody would
show up on so they were called day on
the green and they were an institution
in san francisco they would have two or
three of them every year so we got
invited to play our first day on the
green in 1985. we were
you know playing at 10 o'clock in the
morning when they were opening the gates
and people were coming in but we were
having a great time and we were hanging
out and by the time the day was done we
were all obviously completely ripped out
of our minds and the dressing room
got a
got it beaten took a beating and then
you were summoned a redecoration
redecoration
and then james on monday morning was
summoned
to bill graham's office to uh get the
finger whack from from the legendary man
himself and um
it was yeah he was kind of like the papa
bear you know trying to help all these
bands you know really 60s 70s hippie
stuff and you know it was all about love
and helping people out and we're in
there smashing his dressing room up and
for some reason this watermelon has to
go through that little vent into the
next room
james why why though i wasn't thinking
of anybody else
it was me and the jaeger and my buddies
and this is what we want to do and this
is how we celebrate life
i speak someone else's stuff
you know do you ever shudder at night
i'm being serious like what if you had i
don't know what it's like to physically
pull a tv out of the wall and throw it
out a window but do you ever like sit
there and go oh my god what if that tv
had fallen on a human being and i killed
them my whole life i might have ended up
in prison and i never would have been a
metallica do you ever think seriously
think about that
every day with pretty much every action
i did back then yeah i'm super grateful
that we are standing here
alive
and being able to play and realize that
okay
there's some things that are regrettable
i gotta let them go i can i can clean
all that stuff up but at the end of the
day bill graham was certainly one of
those guys that i respect because he
took the time he took the time and
effort to say hey yeah
uh you are cared about and i seen i've
seen this i've seen this happen i've had
this same talk with keith moon and sid
vicious and i think uh
okay
thanks bye and i walk out
and then i'm thinking all right
i gotta go back in i'll walk back in and
i said you know i
thank you
you know
my dad has never had talks with me about
this i had really no guidance
right
thank you
and i will
i will take this to heart and i will
respect what you said and do my best
the next time i remember we played in
town he had the whole backstage
covered in visqueen which is clear
plastic i mean everything right and duct
tape everything
all the
uh our guitars i mean the food uh tvs
everything was covered
and then i got it it's like this guy is
not only cool he's got a great sense of
humor too
you